[Musique]
vous vous en doutez peut-être les
utilisateurs avec qui vous interagissez
sur twitter facebook ou encore tic toc
ne sont pas toujours de vraies personnes
il s'agit parfois de comptes automatisé
appelé bottes oui les bottes peuvent
simplement servir à des fins
commerciales pour promouvoir un produit
ou encore pour divertir tout simplement
mais ces comptes robotisée existe
souvent aussi pour faire mousser la
popularité d'une personnalité d'un parti
ou d'une idéologie au détriment d'une
autre ces bottes peuvent être très
pratique pour semer la confusion ou pour
disséminer de la désinformation en gros
très utile pour influencer les débats en
ligne on en voit parfois par exemple qui
partagent tous le même contenu
simultanément dans des campagnes
coordonner ce qui peut être organisée
par une ferme de bottes il relaie bien
souvent des messages qui contiennent le
même mot clic cela dit certains bottes
sont pilotés par certaines institutions
au gouvernement et qui s'en servent pour
donner sur twitter par exemple les
conditions routières la météo ou encore
alerter la population sur un danger
imminent comme un tremblement terre par
exemple des petits trucs pour détecter
un bot à vue d'oeil allons-y méfiez-vous
des profils aux noms étranges ou fed une
suite de chiffres et de lettres qui ne
veulent rien dire méfiez vous aussi de
l'absence de photo de profil ou une
photo qui paraît repiquer d'ailleurs
autre indice fraikin qui trahit la
présence de bottes une cadence de tweet
très élevé le martèlement du même type
de message formaté de façon identique
est aussi un indice probant mais
heureusement des outils existent pour
identifier des comptes robotisée comme
par exemple borloo miller qui offre une
analyse approfondie une analyse
statistique de l'activité du compte en
plus de donner une note de 1 à 5 5 est
assurément un bot mais juste pour
compliquer les choses il arrive parfois
qu'un compte soit gérer à la fois par un
humain et un outil automatisé en
alternance les plateformes tente d miné
le plus possible de contrôle baptisée
nuisibles ou encore les faux comptes des
plateformes comme twitter permettent aux
utilisateurs d'identifier leurs comptes
comme étant automatisés un gage de
transparence
mais beaucoup passent néanmoins sous le
radar avec des méthodes de toujours plus
poussée et raffiné sophistiqués pour se
fondre dans la masse grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle notamment
qui permet de produire de faux profils
toujours plus réaliste bref soyez
vigilants et ne croyaient pas toujours
que votre nouvel ami est fait de chair
et d'os
[Musique]